deep inside a dark lab in Zurich
Switzerland engineering students have
been working tirelessly to bring you
this this is not your average
remote-control car
you're right Kiran this all-terrain
vehicle is incredibly versatile and can
go anywhere
well almost anywhere wait whoa whoa
what's happening I wasn't expecting that
I want one this epic robot is named
vertigo but how can it drive up walls
other robot assists have built robots
that can climb walls but usually they do
it with biologically inspired ideas
these guys took a different tactic this
vehicle works with fans to get onto the
wall from the ground the robot scans the
wall to know exactly where it is it then
turns the front propeller all the way
around so instead of pushing forward or
down it's pushing the front of the robot
up then the back propeller flips around
pushing the bottom wheels up against the
wall
once it's vertical both propellers work
together to keep the robot stuck against
the wall the way the propellers stick
this vehicle to the wall is by creating
a frictional force between the tires of
the vehicle and the wall the propellers
generate over ten pounds or four point
five kilograms of thirst now the robot
only weighs 4.5 pounds or 2 kilograms so
there's not only enough thrust to stick
the robot to the wall but enough left
over to drive it about once it's on
there when it comes to the Vertigo
you're either a fan or it'll drive you
up the wall